hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be going over a nice little
middlegame tactic and it's the bishop
sacrifice and if any of y'all play chess
regularly you know that there's nothing
more satisfying than a good sacrifice if
you've ever seen in a mortal game from
the top players around the world you
never see in a mortal game without an
amazing sacrifice and today we're going
to be going over one of the most common
and basic sacrifices that every chess
player needs to know and that is the
light square Bishop sacrifice on the h7
squared and I'm going to go ahead and
get into it and then later on we'll talk
about what you actually need to have in
place to make sure that this works but
this is a prime example of when white as
you can see here we're tied a material
should sacrifice his Bishop on h7 now
black does have the option he can bring
his King to h8 and then if we want to we
can just bring our bishop back to d3 and
continue our salt we're now at the
material and the King side is very much
exposed on the King's black side here
but we really would like the King to
take our bishop and that's what we're
planning for so if the King takes our
bishop on 87 that's completely fine
that's what we wanted we're going to
bring our Knight to g5 now in this
instance we have our pawn here on h4 but
we also have this knight being protected
by c1 so even though this queen is
attacking it from d8 we have two
protectors on this night here and this
nights going to continue to attack this
King now the King is going to move back
to g8 now I do realize that the King has
a few other options he can go to h8 but
then he's going to be quickly made it if
we bring our Queen to h5 he can also
bring his King to g6 and we can bring
our pawn to h5 devastating move because
again he has to continue to move his
King and lastly he can bring his King to
h6 but then we can move our night to
8:00 - excuse me - f7 and we have a
discovered attack with our bishop on c1
so we're going to win that Queen on d8
so I'm going to move the King back to g8
but I know people always leave comments
well Kevin the King has 12 different
moves you didn't cover all of them well
just assume that if he makes it move
that I didn't say it's going to be bad
for them anyway and stop second-guessing
me in my videos but with that said after
he moves to g8 then we're going to bring
our Queen to h5 and really Black has two
options here he can lose his Queen he
can take this night on g5 or he can lose
his king now we already can see now if
he takes the Queen on g5 then we're
going to take the Queen and we're going
to have a devastating attack we're going
to be way up in material and I really
hope that you can win this game so I'm
not going to play the whole game out but
we're going to assume that he tries to
hold on to his King instead and the only
move that he has is rook to e8 trying to
give himself room because if he didn't
we could just come to h7 and it would be
check now from here why it's going to
continue and he's going to take mal on
f7 we're going to just try to eat away
at all the defenders that black has now
from here black only has one legal move
and that is h8 and then we're going to
come back to h5 and again black only has
one legal move that's g8 and now we're
going to come back to h7 as you see here
we could have come to h7 first but we
want to come in and take this pawn on f7
first and then we'll continue as you see
here now black again has only one legal
move to f8
and now we can come to h8 with our queen
now again black only has one legal move
and he's going to come to e7 and from
here we have checkmate so Queen to g7
and this is checkmate as you can see
here it's very important that we have
this pawn here because it's attacking
this d6 pawn which would be a square
that the king could go to an escape now
he'd be running for his life but he
could escape on that square so as you
can see we just completely annihilated
the King side safety that he had built
up here if you originally look at the
position from the beginning it looked
like the King was safe but as we saw
because we had a simple Bishop sacrifice
on h7 it quickly crumbled it and white
won the game easily so there's a few
things that you want to keep in mind
that you really need to be in place for
this to work the first thing is you need
the bishop the light square bishop along
this long diagonal I know this is a
common sense since it has to take this
pawn on h7 but I did want to cover all
the grounds that you have to have in
order for this to work the second one is
you need this knight on f3 and as you
can tell it's very important because
this knight from F 3 is going to come to
g5 here now he could be on h3 but more
times than not he's going to be on f3 if
you're developing correctly he's going
to go from f3 and he's going to go to g5
attacking this King hopefully once he
takes our sacrifice on h7 the next one
that you want to have is your queen on
d1 it's very important that he can come
to this h5 Square after this Knight
moves to g5 very important and the next
one that you want to have as the bishop
on c1 he's adding support to this Knight
because you may not have this pawn here
on h4 but the same time it really makes
as we saw earlier we could move our
Knight away if this King was on h6
and it would be a discovered attack it's
very important that we have
this just in case the King tries to come
down once we move our knight to take
this Queen it's no longer good option
for black because we have our Bishop on
c1 and last and possibly most important
is we need a pawn on e5 and this is very
important because if this pawn is not
here then this Knight can move around
and get into the way or this King will
have an escape route as notably as we
talked about before on d6 so it's very
important right now to have this pawn on
East on e5 now as you can see this setup
right here you may see this in the
French defense this is kind of how it
looks at the beginning it may derive
from another opening but you'll see this
come up quite a bit if it's a close game
in the middle and there's not a lot of
action going on this will happen quite
often so let's take a look at another
example and go ahead and take a look at
this example here and see if you see
anything different on this example and
hopefully you saw that we don't have our
pawn here on e5 I've removed the pawn
here on e5 and the pawn here on c7 to
make the material the same on both sides
but if you look at it now if we take on
h7 again we're giving up 2 points in
material here if he takes on 8 7 we're
not going to bring our Knight to g5 if
he comes back to g8
again we're continue with Queen to h5
but now there's a big difference black
can now bring his knight to f6 and he's
not only blocking the square on h7 that
we would like to attack with checkmate
but he's also attacking our queen on h5
so our Queen's gonna have to do
something and in this case he's going to
have to retreat now this is not good for
white because again we did give up our
bishop to do this so it's very important
as
you can see that this pawn here on e5 is
there so in this case he could take this
knight on f6 and then we would continue
to have our attack there so keep this in
mind let's look going to take a look at
this example and see if you can play
through and see why this won't work and
hopefully you came up with after Bishop
to h7 King takes a seven Knight to g5
King back to g8 and our Queen to h5 that
Black has two options here he can bring
his Bishop to f5 or you can bring his
Queen down to d3 as you can see what
both those did is both of those defended
this h7 pawn so we want to make sure
that when we're doing this sacrifice
that black cannot come and defend the
square on h7 if we have those five
things in place from earlier and black
cannot defend this square at night on h7
then the sacrifice will work but as you
can see here if they can defend this h7
square then it's not going to work and
we're probably not going to do very well
because we've sacrificed a bishop and in
this case it's an open game which
bishops thrive in to open game so this
is not going to be good for us but this
is very important concept to know as far
as win the sacrifice and the bishop
sacrifice from light on the h7 square is
very common so you need to know about it
for your sake and also if someone plays
it against you so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you haven't
already check out the website
www.chesterlaw.com and I'll see you guys
in the next video thanks for watching